foundation researcher marcus hernandez
was a professional in all aspects of his
job he was intelligent being scouted for
a job at the foundation right out of
college he was brave unyielding in the
faces of the horrifying creatures and
dangerous situations that working with
the anomalous practically guaranteed but
most importantly researcher hernandez
was cautious he not only knew that
keeping his hands at a fair distance
from any newly discovered anomalous
objects was a safe way to keep his head
he was also aware that it was sometimes
better to take risks that would further
his knowledge about an anomaly and how
best to contain it sometimes those risks
came with a price like being part of the
first team to study a recently
discovered anomaly
to researcher hernandez it was better to
lose the lives of the ones working to
protect humanity from what lies in the
dark than have any unsuspecting
civilians stumble upon something
potentially life-threatening that's why
he and his team took the assignment of
studying
scp-1437 before anyone else in the
foundation was able to they simply were
not sure of what it was capable of and
researcher hernandez's known attention
to detail and cautious nature could best
help the foundation not only establish
proper containment procedures but also
ensure that their own personnel were
safe while doing so as researcher
hernandez sat in the back of a jeep that
rolled and tumbled over the arid
landscape of the mojave desert he
reviewed what the foundation knew about
the anomaly unfortunately it wasn't much
for starters it was a three meter by
three meter hole in the ground
originally thought to be an ordinary
cave as a result of its deceiving
appearance the anomaly went unnoticed
for decades until the foundation picked
up on a local story that was the talk of
the town for a small group of camping
and hiking hobbyists in nevada a camper
while out exploring and trekking through
the dry dunes of the mojave was struck
in the back of the neck with a u.s
quarter while the object by itself is
harmless it came flying at the camper's
body at an incredibly high speed
shooting from a large hole in the ground
and striking hard enough to break the
skin and wedge itself inside the
camper's neck after reaching the local
hospital and getting the coin removed it
still left a small scar across the back
of the camper's head this unusual event
prompted foundation reconnaissance which
turned out to be entirely warranted as
observation of the surrounding area
found several more objects buried around
the area that were believed to have
emerged from the hull now designated as
scp-14
a small canoe decorated with luminescent
patterns a calculator that added and
subtracted letters instead of numbers
and a rotten apple core were all objects
strewn around the immediate area and if
that's not strange enough attempts to
map out the hole failed as all measuring
equipment was lost after reaching a
certain depth before the initial
observation team picked up and left
scp-1437 shot out large quantities of
rock and dirt for over an hour
confirming that objects emerge from the
hull at high speeds chemical analysis of
the objects found around the area showed
that they were composed of materials
either unknown or not commonly found on
earth to warrant use in mass production
the observation team came up with a
hypothesis
scp-1437 was a hole that led to a
parallel universe and the objects it
shot out originated in said location
researcher hernandez knew that this was
just a hypothesis but he had reviewed
the lab results himself those objects
certainly did not come from anywhere on
earth and if the hole functioned as a
gateway between worlds that could
explain why the measuring equipment was
lost after a certain point the jeep came
to a stop and when researcher hernandez
stepped out he came face to face with
scp-1437
a large hole sitting in the mojave
desert his crew was already hard at work
surveying and excavating the surrounding
area for any other objects the hull had
shot out that had been lost to time a
mobile analysis lab tent was set up in
the distance as well as several trailers
for personnel living on site researcher
hernandez's personal decision to not use
d-class personnel in his research meant
that each risk the
scp-1437 team took had to be calculated
differently they wouldn't send a person
into the hole and risk loss of life when
a drone could serve the same function
without the potential drawbacks but
still the initial observation team lost
all of their equipment while trying to
measure
scp-1437's depth why waste an expensive
drone when the result would most likely
turn out the same it was these decisions
that earned hernandez's fame and respect
at the foundation and over the next few
weeks his team was able to develop a
wide knowledge base regarding scp-1437
and established safe containment
procedures to keep the anomaly hidden
from the public and easy to work with
for foundation personnel first a 2 meter
tall electric fencing unit was built
around the perimeter of scp-1437
this fence would not only keep unwanted
trespassers out but also had defensive
capabilities due to the harmful
electrical charge it could emit upon
contact with an object groups of three
security guard personnel were assigned
to patrol this fence at all times and
they were instructed to deal with any
trespassers through standard foundation
protocol they would be taken into
custody interrogated and as long as they
were unaware of
scp-1437's anomalous properties given a
healthy dose of amnestics and released
back into the general public anything
that emerged from
scp-1437 be it a physical object or a
living organism would be catalogued by
the foundation and tested immediately
for any potential hazards before further
analysis could begin if found to be safe
the items would be studied as much as
possible if not they were stowed away in
an area intended to keep them contained
until a safe way to examine them was
found but perhaps the most important
containment procedure researcher
hernandez established was the
forbiddence of testing with scp-1437
due to the anomaly's mysterious nature
and incredibly likely potential
connection to parallel universes testing
could have grave and unforeseen
consequences when dealing with alternate
or parallel timelines or realities the
foundation is incredibly cautious and
only interacts in ways that they're
absolutely sure will not have any
unexpected damage on baseline reality
that and researcher hernandez wasn't
exactly keen on attracting the attention
of these parallel universes without a
solid understanding of who and what they
were as he would come to find this
inclination proved to be beneficial as
the team observed scp-1437
they documented a number of notable
objects that emerged from the hole each
supposedly originating from a parallel
world the first of which however was not
anything the team hadn't seen before the
initial observation team sent to test
whether
scp-1437 was actually anomalous had
observed the hole emitting a mass of
rock and dirt for over an hour
scp-1437 spewed earth and materials
without stopping filling the surrounding
areas with debris since this was before
the research team theorized the hole was
connected to parallel realities they
weren't sure what to make of it was it a
natural eruption a poorly documented
earthquake that somehow sent chunks of
rock and dirt to the surface and
shooting out of the hull though somewhat
stumped researcher hernandez's team
eventually came to a single solid
conclusion
if
scp-1437 led to a parallel world or
world whoever was on the other side of
the whole may have been attempting to
fill it using natural materials if they
were attempting to fill it could they be
trying to contain it did the parallel
world on the other side of
scp-1437 have its own foundation this
sudden thought gave researcher hernandez
pause and made him reconsider his
hands-off approach to
scp-1437 should his team attempt to
contact whoever was on the other side if
it was a parallel branch of the
foundation this behavior would be
encouraged the foundation communicated
with alternate versions of itself in
time and space all of the time the
department of temporal anomalies was
built around this premise but these were
exceptions not the rules and
communication with alternate foundations
was always carried out with utmost
safety and precaution it was only done
when there was a certainty that risk
would be avoided researcher hernandez
was sure he made the correct decision
and he would stray away from attempting
to contact those on the other side of
the anomaly even if they were another
world's incarnation of the scp
foundation weeks later researcher
hernandez was awoken in the middle of
the night by an excited assistant who
after calming herself down informed him
that
scp-1437 had spat out a new object you
have to forgive her if you were out in
the desert for weeks staring at a hole
waiting for it to do something and it
eventually did it you'd be pretty
excited too when researcher hernandez
ran outside to see what the team was
freaking out about he could have jumped
for joy 2.
scp-1437 wasn't spitting out rocks and
dirt anymore this time it was a map
clearly illustrated to depict the
continent of north america but upon
closer inspection the team noticed some
very apparent differences from a
traditional map in the geography of our
world the map was written entirely in
spanish and the names of countries and
states it listed didn't match their
existing counterparts in fact the entire
border lines of the map were mismatched
out of place and radically different
from anything resembling north america
it listed the government of the entire
continent of north america as
republica popular de aguas nuevas or
when translated to english the people's
republic of new waters this exciting
find was logged and archived and it was
only the first of a series of objects
that emerged from scp-1437
a few days later another object was
documented this time it was a photograph
after initial scans determined the
object to be safe to view not harboring
any dangerous memetic triggers upon
viewing or anything of that nature the
team analyzed the picture to the best of
their abilities they saw a breathtaking
vista of a city skyline unlike anything
possible on this world intertwined with
buildings were massive structures that
appeared to be made out of coral they
wrapped around skyscrapers branching
from the ground and sometimes emerging
from the buildings themselves the coral
broke through the tops of the tallest
buildings putting the man-made titans to
shame in the far background a massive
flying creature can be seen peacefully
floating through the air this
otherworldly visual overwhelmed the team
but after the initial shock wore down a
keen eye junior researcher pointed out
that many of the buildings resembled
known landmarks though they were
radically altered in noticeable ways
this wasn't just any city it was new
york city only this time with coral and
giant floating creatures exactly what
the big apple's been missing this entire
time but this was still comprehensible
and understandable for the foundation
scp-1437's true weirdness was still yet
to come a few days after the photograph
emerged
scp-1437 shot out a truly peculiar find
researcher hernandez and his team were
stumped as to what its purpose was and
what it signified but they determined
the objects to be completely safe and
archived them regardless the items in
question were a series of disks made
from solid gold varying in size but
never being obscenely large accompanying
the disc was a sheet of paper that read
please send more rain the foundation was
understandably puzzled one working
theory researcher hernandez put together
was that whoever was on the opposite
side of scp-1437
was paying tribute to the whole as a
form of worship and was asking the
almighty beings on the other side to
send more rain for whatever reason while
the foundation didn't exactly send the
rain over themselves whoever sent that
request was probably pleased when a
thunderstorm the next week sent torrents
of rainwater into scp-1437
we hope they're happy the most notable
discoveries that emerge from scp-1437
occurred over a multi-year period
previously the research team theorized
that
scp-1437 was connected to a single
reality and that whoever was on the
other side of it was sending objects
through either by chance or by means of
communication this discovery proved that
there wasn't just one parallel world
connecting to scp-1437
but many an unknown amount in fact the
items in question this time weren't just
objects but human cadavers one by one
over the years inner space between the
various oddities that
scp-1437 also spat out were human
corpses dead on arrival the bodies were
clad in foundation issue d-class
uniforms though with some slight
variations this proved that the worlds
connected to
scp-1437 were in fact alternate versions
of the foundation or at least some of
the worlds as there was no way to tell
who what or where the objects that
emerged from scp-1437
came from researcher hernandez and his
team examined the bodies with care and
determined that they were dead long
before they hit the ground and that the
gateway between worlds triggered the
cause of death as they traveled between
realities inside the d-class jumpsuits
the team discovered pieces of paper
manuscripts that detailed their world's
foundation's documentation on
scp-1437 this deliberate inclusion of
documentation signaled to the research
team that there was an attempt at
communication and cooperation from one
world's foundation to theirs but why the
first body was clearly an adequate
physical condition it was protected due
to being clothed in a pressure suit with
an attached oxygen supply the
documentation read similarly to the scp
foundation's documentation though
instead of special containment
procedures and an object class
scp-1437 was given a safety rating and
safety containment procedures these
detail the foundation that was giving
civilians tours of their anomalies where
they could take photographs and even get
close enough to view the anomaly from a
close distance the rest of the file was
similar to what hernandez's team
recorded and listed the following
objects as those that emerged from
scp-14
scp-1437
one small pyramid composed of concrete
large quantities of dirt and rocks a
landscape painting believed to be a
location in scotland according to the
painting its originating universe's sun
is blue and its sky yellow several disks
made from solid gold accompanying the
discs was a sheet of paper reading
please stop plague a photograph of
several scientists all scientists
pictured have unusually long fingers
estimated to be nearly 25 centimeters
long a sheet of paper reading thank you
please send more gifts the file
continued with a notice explaining that
the bodies of orange jumpsuited
individuals holding documentation of the
anomaly emerge from the whole the file's
unfamiliarity with jumpsuits indicate
that this world lacks a concept of
d-class personnel the file mentions that
on the 15th of august 2012 a volunteer
from the foundation marco pertin entered
scp-1432
wearing safety gear taking with him a
copy of this document the second d-class
body examined by hernandez's team was
branded with the phrase property of the
scp corporation the file described an
item with a threat level of little and a
foundation that was more focused on
profit than containment after objects
emerged from the whole they were
authorized to be sold to any interested
collectors objects described by this
version of the foundation include a
statue of what is believed to be a
reptilian entity sporting numerous eyes
and tails large quantities of dirt and
rocks a glass bottle of water a human
femur covered in saliva a cube comprised
of several smaller cubes all of which
are different colors purpose unknown a
soccer ball ball only has five sides the
file included the scp corporation
describing d-class showing up as they
did in other worlds and then the
corporation happily sending several
d-classes of their own through the hull
in an attempt to communicate with
whoever was on the other side the third
d-class body examined was heavily
bandaged and appeared to be blinded
there were lacerations on its arms and
legs and its tongue had been removed the
file described a foundation akin to a
religious cult
scp-1437 was given a heathen level of
unforgivable and its holding measures
described a high priest having to bless
the whole every two years and the need
to perform blood sacrifices into it to
ward off any demons the wild incarnation
of the foundation interpreted as cp 1437
as a portal to the underworld and
described a list of objects emerging
from it it read as follows several discs
made from solid gold accompanying the
disc was a sheet of paper reading please
kill foes large quantities of dirt and
rocks believed to be an attempt by
demons to harm the high priest who was
present at the holding site at the time
the broken remains of a human arm
covered in saliva a photograph of a
metal bird flying away from a city what
appears to be a large mushroom is
visible behind the bird believed to be
an attempt by demons at mocking us a
human eye which moved when touched
believed to be a lesser demon was burnt
immediately unlike the other worlds when
this one received d-classes through
scp-1437
the religious fanatics believed the
bodies to be demons wearing the skin of
men and threw the bodies back in the
hole the next d-class body observed by
hernandez's team was the most curious it
was a heavily emaciated child who had
apparently been lobotomized it described
a foundation that sounds more like an
organization out of a dystopian science
fiction novel than anything else the
file spoke of a group of beings referred
to as our masters above all which the
foundation answered to any objects
emerging from
scp-1437 were brought before the masters
any trespassers were interrogated by the
masters this foundation believed the
objects as cp 1437 shot out were gifts
for the masters their list reads as
follows one diamond large quantities of
dirt and rocks bark from the extinct
quercus buchuli the lower half of a
human body delivering two supervising
servants of our masters above it is
currently unknown how the gift center
was aware of the diet of our masters
above a document was sent into scp-1437
thanking the gift giver for the object
and requesting further tributes to our
masters above a bottle of human intended
wine while they certainly enjoyed the
food of the human body the wine was
clearly misinterpreted for whatever
reason this foundation interpreted the
wine as an assassination attempt on the
masters above all as a result they sent
a large anomalously powered explosive
through scp-1437
and into the world of an unsuspecting
foundation the file continues with a
notice from this foundation's 05-1 which
reads this is a reminder of why we must
be vigilant in our containment
procedures from now on i don't want any
of these gifts being taken out of
containment they are a clear and present
danger to our masters above looks like
researcher hernandez had the correct
idea about not wanting to risk
experimenting with scp-1437
attracting the attention of a reality
where the almighty o5 council answers to
an even more powerful human eating group
of masters above all
no thank you this reality's foundation
is perfectly content alone now go check
out
scp-1322 glory hole and scp-3001 red
reality for more anomalous parallel
universe-related scps